[Music]
today marks one year since prince harry
and meghan markle split with the royal
family became official
after the couple's explosive claims of
racism there have been growing calls
from
inside some commonwealth nations to end
their association with the monarchy
so now many are asking what exactly is
the commonwealth
it's made up of dozens of nations mostly
former british colonies including
australia and jamaica and now the
question is is it still relevant today
we asked mts taeb to find out for us
[Applause]
it was 1947 and elizabeth still a
princess
made a now historic speech from south
africa i declare before you all
that my whole life whether it be long or
short
shall be devoted to your service and to
the service
of our great imperial family to which we
all belong
the princess's declaration of devotion
was in part to what's known as the
commonwealth of nations
and has now come to define her nearly
70-year reign
as queen as we celebrate the friendship
spirit of unity and achievements of the
commonwealth
we have an opportunity to reflect on a
time
like no other this certainly is a time
like no other for the royal family
the monarch's annual commonwealth day
address was eclipsed by harry and
megan's explosive interview with oprah
which aired just hours later in the us
there's several conversations there's a
conversation
with you with harry about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like
that comment sent shockwaves throughout
the queen's beloved commonwealth
which is made up mainly of countries
with large black and brown populations
says professor of commonwealth studies
philip murphy
the commonwealth is is what makes the
british monarchy special
so having that genuinely global role
in a way that no other monarchy in the
world has
and it was very much hoped i think that
harry and megan
would be a kind of accessible face of
the commonwealth to young people
now that's not going to happen so what
exactly is the commonwealth
it's 54 countries spanning the globe
most are former colonies of the british
empire
and for 16 of those nations the queen
continues to be the head of state
in a largely symbolic role but critics
from within the commonwealth say
that symbolism serves as a modern
reminder of britain's cruel colonial
past
a pass which includes theft on a global
scale the enslavement of millions
and the entrenchment of deep racial
divisions
harry and meghan's bombshell interview
is now supercharging the debate over
whether commonwealth countries
should break away from the crown and
become independent republics
i think that there is a lot of courage
in the fact that meghan markle was able
to share her experiences and
jagmeet singh is the leader of one of
canada's main opposition parties the new
democrats
if something is no longer benefiting us
it doesn't actually help
people in their day-to-day lives what is
the point of having that association
megan was the first woman of color in
the modern royal family
and it was hoped she'd help usher in an
era where the firm as it's known
would be more inclusive i am here with
you as a mother
as a wife as a woman
as a woman of color and as your sister
that speech on a royal tour of south
africa was hailed for megan's
celebration of her own biracial identity
while in a majority black commonwealth
nation something no other royal could do
and now just 18 months later isn't
likely to again
we reached out to buckingham palace for
comment on the calls from within some
commonwealth nations to sever ties to
the crown
but was declined the queen however did
respond to harry and megan's revelations
by releasing a statement saying
the issues of race are concerning and
will be addressed by the family
privately a pledge of private
introspection
which may not be enough to silence the
increasingly vocal calls to pull apart
the commonwealth
an institution the 94 year old monarch
has dedicated most of her life
to holding together for cbs this morning
india
london people in the commonwealth are
really having this discussion there was
a poll conducted in canada a
commonwealth
country after the oprah interview more
than half of people said that they think
the monarchy
should be abandoned by canada and then
48 percent say
said they now see the monarchy as a
racist institution this is right after
the interview
wow so it's changing the conversation
symbolism do you still want it to be
yours many
on many levels yeah but many people
still feel connected to the queen they
grew up in these countries
the queen is beloved yes absolutely